Kellyanne Conway is the counselor to the
president she joins me right now in the
North Lawn thanks for being here
we just heard Deirdre in New York
talking about the economy the markets
today for a president who touts the
markets when you see a big hit like this
is it a dangerous thing to tout the
markets as much as he does about the
economy the president tonight though
will recap what has been a tremendous
year for our prosperity and our security
bread and there's no mistaking that the
Dodgers are still over 26,000 points it
made many record highs and doing only in
large part to his the centerpiece of his
economic agenda his tax cut but also the
regulatory framework really getting more
in line not being so burdensome the
energy development that you've seen
I think striking at the heart of
Obamacare where 30 million Americans
still deny have health insurance post
Obama care having repealed the
individual mandate as part of his tax
plan all of that is leading to untold
prosperity and not just in the wage the
wage increases and the bonuses and the
capital investments you're seeing from
some 275 companies and employers but
also in people's retirement securities
their 401ks or pensions their
educational investments and so he will
continue to be able to tell an economic
record of prosperity that's very
important it's not just about the stock
market it's about all the other elements
that are under girding this economy that
consumer confidence manufacturing
confidence small business information
confidence numbers the unemployment
numbers that you and Ron Roberts were
talking about in your earlier package
yeah one of the reasons the market took
a hit today is because of health care
yes the president acknowledged that you
and I were you know one of the questions
is how do you fix that
and I very divided Washington right now
this president remains committed to
finding a better way to provide the
millions of Americans who lack
affordable accessible quality health
care they relied to they couldn't keep
their plan of their doctor and we're
still cleaning up that mess for many
Americans who felt that they were never
made whole by a system that has squeezed
them out because of the increasing
premiums the insurers fleeing the
exchanges and of course the young and
healthy being too smart to be trapped
into going into these exchanges and so
we want to make sure that more Americans
have
access the president has talked very
positively about for example brett
associated health plans so that if you
are one of those folks who do not get
their health coverage like you and i do
through our employers or like others do
i'm through the government then you can
pull together so you're sharing the cost
and sharing the risk those would be is
self-employed or small business owners
for example the president's also talked
about competitive rates across state
lines
why can you and i buy our car insurance
across state lines right now but not our
health insurance i'm also possibly block
writing medicaid to the states so that
those closest to the people in need know
how to administer that money one of the
things the president will talk about is
the economy but also reaching across
party yes you had the Senate Minority
Leader Chuck Schumer today saying this
about the president and they come
President Trump was handed an already
healthy economy by his predecessor like
many things in his life he inherited the
healthy economy here are two words we
won't hear president Trump say tonight
about the economy thanks to Obama
because much of the growth in 2017 was
created by President Obama's policies
thoughts on that people should maybe
swear under oath before they take to the
aisle well the center on occasion and
here's why you don't have a single
company out there saying I now and
making billions of dollars of
repatriated money or capital investments
like Exxon move Allah said like Apple
computers have said because of the Obama
economy they're saying I'm doing it
because of the Trump tax cut so people
are drawing that nexus between the tax
cut and Jobs Act that just passed a
month ago Brett and what they're doing
now with their employers and in the
larger community investments and also if
you look at the Quinnipiac poll in 2017
sixty six percent of Americans who were
surveyed said that the economy is either
quote excellent or good that's double
the number that it was in the four
previous years of the last
administration so that's just simply not
true
look apple can Apple I believe the
principles at Apple we're big fans of
the last president I'm sure if they were
able to say we create we're bringing
20,000 US jobs here we are repatriating
billions of dollars
we're making capital investments I'm
sure they would love to have seven and
last demonstration they simply couldn't
do it because we had an anemic 2% or
less growth rate GDP already exploited
under this president and we had and we
had tax increases we did not have tax
cuts we had a corporate tax rate of
thirty five percent this president this
Republican Congress brought that down to
21 percent oftentimes State of the Union
addresses are shopping lists they are
lists of things they want to get done
the presidents want to get done one of
the things that's talked about is
infrastructure at the same time there's
a lot of concern up on Capitol Hill
about the deficit and debt here's a
candidate Trump talking about that we
owe 18 trillion dollars we're going to
21 trillion and ultimately 24 which is a
magic word you know 24 trillion that's
the magic number that's like the point
of no return and we're they're very
quickly we're gonna end up being another
Greece and maybe we're gonna end up
being another Detroit because that's
where our country is going we need
proper leadership if you look at the
national debt clock now it stands at
twenty point six trillion dollars there
are Republicans and Democrats who have
found the light if you will when it
comes to deficit in debt what do you
think about that as you look to this
agenda of what to do next
this president it continues to be very
concerned about our debt and deficit
right there's no question he's not
responsible for the way it's exploded
over the last several administrations at
the same time we can't only look at that
and not consider our crumbling roads and
bridges upwards of 50,000 bridges over
I've read in some reports are in
disrepair and we know that also our air
traffic control system it was designed
for a time when we had roughly 100,000
passengers annually we now have close to
1 billion B billion passengers annually
flying through the air traffic control
system so we would think this is a
nonpartisan issue crying out for
bipartisan support and we hope that it
is this president is committed to two
major principles under his
infrastructure plan one is to invest at
least one trillion dollars in that
infrastructure and secondly is to bring
our permitting process down from eight
to ten years to about two it's done in
other countries like Australia where
they they give plenty of time for people
to comment it
you want to criticize the project you
can but you don't have 20 years to do
that you can't keep getting these
extensions and so we really want to
shrink the permitting time it'll cost
money and then we'll improve the safety
and security of those of us all of us
who travel so last thing if you're gonna
paint a broad picture for somebody who's
going to tune in tonight state of the
unions sometimes don't draw you know the
the huge crowd but it is the time when
all government comes together and you're
in the same place and you're talking
about an agenda if you're to paint a
picture of this speech what would it be
a couple of things one is pay attention
to both the tone and the content of this
president tonight I think you will find
both of them very inviting very
conciliatory for a unifying positive and
uplifting and I certainly hope people
across the aisle see that and feel that
I'm number two I'm so grateful to God
that Steve Scalise will be there in the
hall because when you go back and you
look at 2017 I would say one of the
darkest days for me having been here the
full year was the day that mr. Scalise
and others were shot and the baseball
field in Virginia we don't talk enough
about that they were moments away from
real tragedy and I'm so grateful to God
that he'll be there with others in that
Hall also the first lady's guests are
really special I've had a small hand and
witnessing that process and she has
invited such wonderful powerful stories
of the best of America some of these
stories are tragic and some of them are
patriotic but they're all part of the
American spirit how we overcome how we
come together in the face of tragedy and
also what we can do as a nation to pull
together Joanna thank you thank you